a woolly mammoth cloned in five years
and let me get a Big Mac and a life
jacket Vsauce Kevin here this is mine oh
cool it's mega man's guts these
anatomical statues show the innards of
some of your favorite characters
including Yoshi and victory of mine now
Stewie's head is not actually the bosses
market logo but the LG logo just my eat
ghosts and meatballs is that Frank
Zappa's mustache or Toyota trucks is
that the Dodge Ram logo or a nice
motorcycle
I wonder how fast that little baby go
let's talk video game look-alikes
terminators Kyle Reese looks like the
cover of Metal Gear big boss looks like
Sean Connery a rock and David Bowie
looks like just about everyone except
King Hippo probably knew a thing or two
about fast food secret menus these are
items not on the menu that you can order
if you know about them Burger King has
the suicide burger four patties four
slices of cheese bacon and secret sauce
that burger has the hypocrit which is a
veggie patty topped with bacon but in
and out tops them all with the five by
five five patties five slices of a
screwed let's do a 100 by 100 yeah there
we go now if you want a lighter snack
just take a laser beam and pop your
popcorn one kernel at a time this is the
most powerful laser you can legally own
and you can buy it at the website you'll
find in the links below
oh nice it's Lola from GTA 4 hey how
many fingers are you holding up six
oh and the Triforce is real seriously
just take out a $1 bill you'll find it
and thanks to BuzzFeed if you put your
iPod earbuds of your nose the music will
come out your mouth amazing finally
let's look at a brief history of gaming
cool it begs the question what's the
oldest retro gaming system that you own
and finally I'm going to leave you guys
with a riddle the first person to get
the riddle right and explain how they
got their answer will be featured at the
top of the sauces channel page as our
genius of the week if you're 12 feet
from your car and each step brings you
half the distance to your car how many
steps will it take to reach your car
leave your answer in the comments below
and as always thanks for watching
you